欢迎来到四遍
今天我们来聊一个很多人都感同身受的话题
到底要怎么才能让AI真正懂我
我们可能都有过这种体验
就是跟AI对话
感觉就像每天都在跟一个新同事沟通
你得一遍又一遍地重复那些背景信息
心里特别累
那相关的材料就提出了一个很有意思的观点
说问题的核心可能不是AI模型本身不够聪明
而是我们管理和构建它上下文的方式
好像不太对
对 这就引出了我们今天的核心议题了
就是说我们是应该投入巨大的经历
通过什么本地化的知识库
标准化的技能
去精心打造一个高度个性化的AI工作流
还是说这么做其实太折腾了
完全是低估了AI平台自身能力的发展速度
我的看法是
要想获得真正的AI生产力
我们必须主动去构建和管理AI的知识体系
把它培养成我们真正的第二个大脑
我倒是觉得这种深度定制的本地化方法
听起来很酷 但门槛太高了
而且一不小心
很容易就把自己搞成一个信息孤岛
我们更应该做的是
学会利用那些越来越强大
极程度越来越高的AI平台和模型本身
我之所以这么坚持
其实是因为我自个儿有很深的体会
你看今年年中
我就做了一个挺大的决定
我停用了所有我过去依赖的云端笔记
像是Notion 石墨笔记这些
把里面几年的积累全部导成了最基础的Markdown文件
就存在我自己的电脑上
为什么要这么折腾呢
因为我发现和AI的沟通之所以那么低效
根源就在于它对我一无所知
它没有记忆
你今天交给它的东西
明天它就忘了
只有让AI能长期稳定地接触到我的个人知识库
我的读书笔记我的项目复盘
甚至是我每天写的日记
它才能慢慢地形成一种长期记忆
才能真正理解我的工作模式
我的思维习惯
知道我过去做过什么
踩过哪些坑
所以说这已经不是换个工具那么简单了
这是从根本上想去改变我和AI的协作关系
把它从一个什么都懂点
带什么都不经的通用问答期
培养成一个真正懂我的数字助理
嗯 我完全理解你这种追求个性化的动机
谁不希望AI能跟自己心有灵犀呢
但我觉得你这个方案
本质上是把本该由平台方解决的问题
过度地转移给了用户
你这是要求每个用户都得成为自己AI的上下文工程
要会管理文件 搭建信息架构
这对于绝大多数人来说 根本不现实嘛
而且 我们得动态地看问题啊
你刚才提到了这些痛点
比如AI的静态知识 记忆缺失
上下文口不够长
恰恰是现在所有大模型公司
在拼了命解决的问题
你想想 一年前我们还纠结几千个词源的窗口
现在百万级词源的模型已经出来了 对吧
更聪明的记忆机制也在不断的迭代
所以说啊
我们不应该基于当前技术的局限
去费那么大劲
搭建一套可能很快就会过时地复杂的个人系统
用户花大量精力去手动管理上下文的必要性
正在飞快地减少
我觉得我们看问题的重点不太一样
你担心的是信息不够多
我担心的是信息不够对
就算未来上下文口真的无限大
它也解决不了信息的质量和组织问题
这就好像你让一个新员工入职
然后直接扔给他公司过去10年所有的邮件和文档
指望他立刻就能上手干活
这可能吗
他肯定会被信息的噪音给淹没掉
关键永远在于如何体谅和组织有效信息
所以我们必须从现在这种
临时的一次性的提示词工程
进化到一种可附用标准化的技能工程
等一下
你说的这个技能我听着怎么
嗯
怎么有点像一个包装的更好听
结构更复杂的提示词模板呢
如果是这样的话
那它不是显著增加了我们创建和维护的负担吗
不完全是
模板就像是填空体
每次都得把所有信息重新填进去
很死板
而我说的技能它更像是一个小小的APP
我给你举个材料里提到的例子
比如整理会议机要这个任务
我可以创建一个核心的会议机要技能
它就像一个APP
它知道整个流程
比如先要识别参会人
再体链核心议题
最后总结行动点
然后呢我只需要告诉它
这次是项目复盘会
它就会自动去调用专门为复盘会准备的规则
比如要加上经验教训这一项
如果我告诉它这是周会
它就自动调用周会的规则
加上下周计划这一项
它只会加载它需要的模块
而不是把所有规则一股脑的三进上下纹理
这才是真正的智能
是把一个专家的隐性指示
沉淀成AI可以稳定执行的数字资产
而不是简单的复制粘贴
嗯
你这个设计听起来是很精巧
但我有一个很现实的问题
如果我的工作流程变了怎么办
比如我们团队这周
突然决定所有会议计要里
都要增加一个风险评估项
我是不是得像个程序员一样
回去找到那个叫SKL.MD的文店
然后小心翼翼的修改里面的代码或者规则
这听起来比我直接用嘴告诉AI一句话
以后计要里都加上风险评估要麻烦多了吧
这反而降低了灵活性
而且对于更复杂的任务
未来的方向可能根本就不是给一个
通用AI安装各种固化的本地技能
现在更前沿的思路是多智能体架构
也就是让一群各有所长的AI协同工作
一个负责搜集资料
一个负责写代码
一个负责作图
由一个总管来调度他们
清华之前那份恒火的艺人公司报告里
也提到了这个趋势
我们应该让AI自己去协作进化
而不是我们去像大勒高一样
为它预设好每一个步骤
你看啊
我们之所以要费这么大劲
去打造这些本地化的技能
它不仅仅是为了效率
它背后有一个更根本的原因
那就是我们到底信不信得过
把自己的核心知识和工作流程
完全交给一个云端平台
这就涉及到了数据隐私和所有权的问题
我为什么这么长调本地化
因为我亲身经历过
我曾经花了好几个月的时间
在一个知名的
online notebook里训练它的AI助手
教它我的写作风格
我的思考逻辑
结果呢
那个服务商一调整算法
或者更新了模型
我所有的努力一夜之间都摆废了
它又变回了那个什么都不懂的通用AI
从那以后我就明白了
最核心的知识体系
必须牢牢掌握在自己手里
让AI的长期记忆
建立在用户完全可控的数据之上
这是构建一个可信赖的AI伙伴的基石
我非常理解对数据隐私的担忧
但这种为了绝对安全而牺牲功能性的做法
代价太大了
这种彻底的本地化策略
会造成一个非常严重的信息割导
AI之所以强大
很大一部分能力
源于它能连接和处理海量的实实信息
如果你把AI完全关在你本地的
一推Markdown文件里
就等于切断了它跟外部API
实时数据库和整个网络的连接
这不又跟艺人公司报告里说的
通过API集成和低代码平台
去连接各种数字员工的趋势背道而驰了吗
AI应该是我们连接数字世界的桥梁
而不是一个
嗯 只能帮我们整理就笔记的
档案管理员 对吧
我不认为这是个非刺激被选择
本地知识库是AI理解
我这个核心的基础
是它的记忆中书
而外部的工具和API
是它执行任务的手和脚
这两者是互补的 不是互斥的
打个比方
AI可以在我的本地知识库里
先学习我过去所有项目报告的
写作风格和分析框架
这是它的大脑在学习
然后它调用外部API
去获取最新的销售数据
这是它的手在干活
最后它用我习惯的格式
生成一份我一看就懂的报告
没有本地的大脑
它拿回来的数据
就只是一堆冰稳的数字
你说的这个场景
现在有更灵活
更主流的技术可以实现
比如现在很火的
检设增强生成
也就是RAG嘛
你可以把它想象成是
给AI办了一张
你私人图书馆的技术卡
你不需要提前把图书馆里
所有的书都搬到AI的脑子里
让它背下来
AI只需要在回答问题的时候
拿着这张卡
去你的私有资料库里
不管是本地文件
还是云吨数据库
快速查一下
找到最相关的那几页信息
结合这些信息再来回答你
这样既能利用你的私有知识
又能保证数据安全
而且比你内众把所有东西
都预加在进去的方式
要灵活得多
我们人也不需要背下整个图书馆
我们只需要知道
怎么用搜索引清就行了
AI也是一个道理
你说的RAG技术确实很好
但它也引出了我们辩论的
第三个层面
实践的可行性
无论是配置RAG
还是你之前说的多智能体
对普通用户来说
技术门槛依然很高
而我体倡的这套工作流
恰恰是实现
一人公司这种超级个体模式的核心
它就像是把一个创始人的经验
和决策能力
变成AI可以随时调用的软件
这样一来
AI就不再只是个工具
而是你的数字分身
让你一个人就能完成过去
一个团队才能做到的事
我知道
初期需要投入很多精力
去建立这个体系
比如整理笔记 封装技能
但这个过程一旦完成
后面就可以一键调用
大幅降低长期的沟通成本
对于那些追求极致效率的
超级个体来说
我认为这是必经之路
恕我直言
这个账我真的算不过来
这种模式的试用范围实在太窄了
它要求用户
得具备相当强的技术能力
比如要熟练使用Gate
做版本控制
要习惯用Markdown写作
要理解API是什么
甚至还要能自己封装脚本
这实际上不是一个
给普通人的工作流
这是一个为程序员
或者技术爱好者设计的
AI集成开发环境
一个AI IDE
对于广大的数量庞大的普通用户
AI的未来一定在于开箱集用的
异用性
而不是要求他们人人都去成为
个人信息架构师
我们应该期待和推动平台方
提供更智能的上下文管理能力
比如材料里提到的混合搜索
结果重排序
动态工具发现等等
把这些复杂的上下文工程任务
下放给每个用户
在我看来
这是一种倒退
而不是进步
我相信
要想和AI进行真正深度的协作
必然需要我们自己进行
系统性的思考和设计
指望平台提供一个万能的
开箱集用的解决方案
是不现实的
因为最宝贵最有效的上下文
永远是关于你个人的知识
和独一无二的工作流程
通过主动构建AI的知识库
把我们的工作流程标准为
可附用的技能
我们才能将AI从一个通用的工具
转变为一个真正
理解我们需求的
高效可靠的伙伴工具
这是一种
先难后异的长期投资
是真正意义上的区迅化AI
让它为你所用
而被动的接受平台给你的一切
我则认为
虽然结构化的交互很有价值
但我们
可能不应该过分执着于
去构建一个复杂
而且封闭的个人系统
AI技术本身正以前
所谓的速度在进步
今天我们费尽心力
构建的本地工作流
很可能明天
就会被模型自带的
更强大的能力所取代
真正的效率
或许在于保持灵活性
随时准备好去拥抱
和利用市场上最先进
最易用的工具
而不是把自己束缚在一套
自己搭建的
可能很快又过时的体系里
我们应该学习的
是如何与一个
不断进化的智能体共舞
而不是试图为它打造
一个移程不变的笼子
今天的探讨
实际上触及了
人机协作的一个核心问题
我们到底应该在多大程度上
去改造自己的工作方式
来适应AI的现状
又可以在多大程度上
期待AI来主动适应我们的需求
或许真正的答案
就在于动态地
寻找这两者之间的平衡点
材料中分享的这些深入思考和实践
无疑为我们探索这条路径
提供了极具价值的试讲